depuis 51 mois cet homme se bat contre
la plus grande multinationale de
fast-food l'âme actors il y a dix ans
raymond dayan faisait le même chemin en
sens inverse avec dans son attaché-case
le contrat du siècle
moyennant 1 % de redevance alors que les
autres franchisés et versent aujourd'hui
11 et demi pour cent raymond dayan
obtenait l'exclusivité pour 30 ans et de
l'implantation et de l'exploitation de
malters pour paris la région parisienne
et la normandie
aujourd'hui dans son attaché-case il y à
un autre dossier marc thomas contre mark
toner je suis l'un d'eux est censé avoir
le plus heureux des hommes
peut-être qu'on bien comme ça au monde à
n'avoir 21 je vais voir chiffres exacts
mais où des hommes je l'avais notre
équipe et ça ça n'arrange pas mcdonald's
en général ils rachètent quand ils
est-il qu une seule personne en a
beaucoup
soyez tout la tendance en 1969
j'enverrai ce moment là cinq magasins au
nord de chicago et quatre magasins ont
subi pas moins cinq occasions dont le
chic à locon contient un territoire très
important c'est aller qui intéresse le
nom éventuellement pour ouvrir d'autres
restaurants étant donné que j'avais la
première option refusée si jamais voulu
dire que ça devait passer par vous devez
penser par moi ça va territoire excusé
pour l'incident
donc on était un peu exclusive toute
l'histoire acquis sous lens territoire
de bromont uniquement à mettre offert
pour donner du sens et aujourd'hui
combien y at-il de mcdonald's dans votre
ancien territoire de chicago je peux
vous dire exactement vous a plu c'est un
très grand territoire henri crotte
visage
je t'échange ton territoire de chicago
pour la france il ne croyait pas que
mcdonald's pouvait s'implanter ici
la vérité vous n'y croyez pas vont se
dire bon bilan france qui s'en foutent
et parce que moi je me débarrasse
d'ailleurs c'est terminé mais là c'était
dois me croyez pas bien sûr eh bien je
crois que le fast food en lui-même sa
phénomène comme l'eau saxons plus tôt le
matin n'était pas prêt en cas à prendre
ce genre de restauration adaptée à ce
genre de la nation la france le pays de
la bonne nourriture c'est le véhicule
nerfs c'est là où maxime s'y trouvent
lasserre deux meilleurs restaurants et
venir le introduire une restauration
complètement étrangère c'est que d'abord
la nique royaume
[Musique]
comment est ce que vous vivez ce procès
avec mcdonald's je suis obligé de suivre
mon mari en principe est entre la fin de
la journée me raconte ici ce qui se
passe alors j'essaye de lui remonter le
moral ou les séfarades
c'est à dire que les coutumes nous avons
certaines façons de faire certaines
façons de de respecter certaines façons
de voir les choses
alors si vous voulez c'est la famille
c'est comme je vous ai dit c'est la fête
[Musique]
m
alors ça va
[Musique]
nous avons gardé nos traditions
marocaines mais par un mes beaux parents
sont d'origine marocaine et moi j'ai été
élevé à la marocaine et nous gardons
exactement les mêmes traditions comme
l'enseigné ma mère ma belle mère si la
marche
non
[Musique]
elle est l'illustration du rêve
américain est ce qu'on vous dit ce qu'on
dit ouais ça vaut rester je suis
vraiment car la carnation du rêve
américain
c'est le seul pays au monde où un aigle
à l'esprit d'entreprise qui a une belle
idée peut venir est vraiment faire sa
chose
toutes les professions ouvertes les
banquiers sont prêts relais des duos
main pour la personne veut vraiment
travailler six mètres et figuratif je
suis quand même en 1960 je vous aiderai
dépassement intérieur
les gérants pause je sais pas tu as j'ai
rencontré
responsable mondial de formats faire
d'agréables soirées crois je le
découvrais leurs bureaux leurs maisons
personnelles
maison personnelle des cadres supérieurs
d'où l'introduction en banal
depuis cinq ans raymond dayan n'était
jamais retourné dans ses neuf
restaurants de chicago nous l'avons
suivi et malgré l'interdiction formelle
nous avons filmé son ancien territoire
il est bien évident qu'avec un tel
procès et un tel enjeu les deux parties
redoubler de prudence droit à l'erreur
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez commencé en faisant les uns
bancaire et bien sûr commencer à tout
faire ok mais vous savez lire vos
guerres en france en 1972 j'avais ouvert
ce magasin je te le promets à savoir des
hamburgers il fallait en trouver le
jouet en hauteur pour elle pour trouver
des gens font fausse route
[Musique]
rigoureusement identique de tokyo a ri
au john r chaque morceau de viande
contient la même quantité de graisse
pèse exactement le même poids et vient
garnir des petits pains qui répondent
aux mêmes exigences de standardisation
une standardisation jusque dans les
moindres détails
tout est réglé par ordinateur les
emplacements calculé au millimètre près
les gestes à la seconde précise les
moitiés de secondes perdues
s'additionnent en minute
écrire et croque dans sa bible des
standards livre de chevet de tous
marmitons mcdo qui se respecte des
robots humains réagissent à des signaux
sonores et lumineux et donne précisément
le moment où la viande sera pressé
retourner retirer à billets et garni par
des pistolets à moutarde ou à ketchup
les fournisseurs auxquels les
propriétaires d'une licence achète la
vie rendent les petits pains les
gobelets en carton sont choisis et
imposer de façon uniforme par mac dans
notre chicago et petites boulettes de
viande la longueur des frites la
température des fritures celle des
plaques de cuisson sont surveillés par
une armée d'inspecteurs qui passe sans
cesse à l'improviste pour les contrôler
en salle tout est fait pour séduire mais
ne pas retenir ray kroc a interdit les
téléphones publics les juke box et
autres appareils distributeurs et les
sièges
lorsqu'il y en a n'insiste pas vraiment
à la rêverie
aux soldes bézieux
en france on a bien essayé de vie c'est
un béret sur le prêt à manger mais le
fast-food savoure sa vengeance
c'est vrai les viennoiseries marche fort
elles couvrent 60 6% du marché mais les
études donnent le hamburger gagnant on
en a vendu 12 millions et demi en 1981
et il s'en vendra 100 millions en 1990
la socopa premier groupe européen de la
viande paris elle aussi sur le fast food
et vient de lancer coup sur coup ses
deux premiers restaurants ont mais vous
copier une formule américaine vous
prenez un non américain et vous avez
bien peu confiance dans le concept
français puisque vous pensez qu'il faut
singer les américains pour pouvoir
s'implanter et chez vous et ailleurs on
veut pas singer les américains il faut
toujours être content il faut toujours
dans un dans une opération de ce genre
là il faut compte qu'il ya de meilleur
chez les autres il adapté français parce
que prouver que le fast food c'est ce
qu'il ya de meilleur chez les américains
non mais disons que mon et simplement et
certains toute façon c'est parce qu'elle
meilleur chez les a
comme il ya une idée et qui correspond
indiscutablement à une évolution des
moeurs l'ordre sur le plan alimentaire
si vous aviez pris un nom français vous
pensez que ça ce serait moins bien
vendus ont 100 calories pour votre
soi-disant repas complet est-ce que vous
ne trouvez pas que c'est un peu beaucoup
je vais prêcher france mais je crois que
bon sang je vous la firme 11 100
calories et quand vous parlez des états
unis où probablement le pays qui a le
plus de problème de surcharge pondérale
on voit dans la rue des baleines est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une bonne
chose
d'amener cela ici mais c'est richie
quelques escrocs jeu en général dans une
journée hommage sous une forme ou une
autre
du pain de la viande des légumes
eysseric les fruits et légumes
benjamin malric sans aucun intérêt non
pas du tout dans le big mac
nous aurons des soldes la sauce de big
mac et ipad fait d'accord c'est à base
de sucre nous avons des cours des choses
si la sauce ou recette à base de légumes
y'a plus rien dans ces légumes la
belgique de l'italie pixels minéraux
rien mais si rien n'est aussi ce sont
des calories sans aucun intérêt
nutritifs
est-ce que vous avez conscience que
c'est cela que vous importez
il ya 240 millions d'années qui a été au
rendez sur la nourriture dans un
restaurant fast-food est assez typique
de la nourriture moyenne américaine
peut-être même un peu plus mauvais total
repeint provoque malheureusement décarie
des dérèglements de la tension des
maladies cardiaques des commotions
cérébrales
il provoque du diabète et de l'obésité
en effet les fesses ou deux contiennent
la plupart du temps beaucoup de sel et
de graisses en revanche peu d'hydrates
de carbone ou de fibres nutritifs mais
il ya encore d'autres petits problèmes
on y trouve difficilement des vitamines
a et c
parce que précisément dans les
restaurants fast food
il n'y a ni fruits ni légumes le sucre
pose-t-il un problème
le sucre est assurément un problème dans
l'alimentation des américains environ
20% de notre nourriture et du sucre les
limonades les sodas les milkshakes que
l'on trouve bien sûr dans les fast-foods
et encore d'autres produits les
restaurants fast-food contribuent
considérablement à ce problème du sucre
le sucre c'est évident provoque des
caries de l'obésité et chez bien des
gens vraisemblablement des maladies
cardiaques et du diabète
le hamburger s'est même payé une
université où l'on délivre des diplômes
de bachelor en hamburger au logis et un
certificat s pommes de terre frites en
deux semaines de cours intensifs ont
fait ingurgiter aux futurs managers de
ses restaurants le système mcdonald's
qui va de l'épluchage des pommes de
terre
aux pommes frites et si nous en croyons
un professeur auxiliaire de l'université
jusqu'à ce que leur sang se transforme
en ketch hockey l'objectif c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est de développer
ensemble le service my canal parce qu'il
faudra que nous arrivions dès le départ
c'est à développer en 30 secondes un
contact avec le client par le moyen du
sourire et de contact visuel
ok je m'explique l'autre jour je sortais
de chez moi je m'étais engueulé avec ma
femme je ferme la porte qui m'en vais
alors quand j'étais très mauvaise humeur
pour les travailler j'ai voulu aller
manger quelque chose dans un café et je
suis arrivé il y avait un gars qui
marqua une pour mes yeux imaginez-vous
maintenant avec toute cette histoire que
j'ai eu
imaginez vous que j'arrive devant
quelqu'un agréable souriant belle jeune
fille bonjour monsieur vous désirez je
vais chez tous
le message c'est un petit peu la
philosophie mcdonald's on peut traduire
vendre le mot philosophie dire qu'il ya
un dynamisme
il y a
une façon de travailler il ya une
ambiance et tout ça je dois le
transmettre aux gens pour qu eux mêmes
puissent transmettre à d'autres encore
si vous voulez mcdonald's c'est une
grande famille
ok mon rôle à moi c'est de transmettre
cette image ma famille ça c'est très
américain ce que vous avez l'impression
qui a une famille chez madonna travaille
comme la famille entre nos sols j'ai
l'impression d'une leçon bien apprise
est ce que je me trompe
qu'est ce qu'on vous a appris depuis
trois ans j'ai mal partout
[Musique]
vous avez dit famille
nous critiquons avant tout la manière
dont sont traités les ouvriers les
ordres cinglant le style de direction
autoritaire le ton assez brutale dans
beaucoup de ces restaurants et le
sempiternel vite vite vite
et puis beaucoup de brûlures aux bras
des conditions de travail peu sur des
coupures venant des différentes machines
et nous avons également un grand
problème d'intimidation sexuelle riz
gérant qui importunent les femmes
cela dépend bien sûr du restaurant mais
nous recevons constamment de nombreuses
plaintes
comment on réagit burger king et
mcdonald's faveau tentative d'organiser
les employés ils essaient de démolir les
syndicats comme personne ne l'a jamais
fait mcdonald par exemple organisé la
veille du vote syndicales une soirée
disco avec des jeux loto concours
d'isère et prix en espèces pour les
employés puis ils ont offert un dîner
avec six plats d'un jambon de tout au
fond ils ont soudoyé le personnel
c'était le clou de leur campagne qui a
duré six semaines
c'est comme ça ils ont voulu empêcher
les employés d'adhérer au syndicat
ils sont très forts président a réagi
style aussi dans les restaurants eux
mêmes
oui là aussi il y a eu des jeux de
hasard et il traitait très bien les
employés n'ont pu ni personne huit à dix
semaines pendant lesquelles le syndicat
a été le regarder et à peine le scrutin
dit les lieux qu'ils ont recommencé à
utiliser les vieilles ficelles et
aujourd'hui si vous gagnez votre procès
vous avez l'intention
combien de mcdonald's dans votre
territoire au lieu de la plage pour 152
sont toujours avec une franchise de 1
pour ça un pour cent qui éventuellement
montrent le chemin complet le mans est
venu pour ça et puis après 2 2% s'est
échelonnée sur certaines années à
combien d'années vous paierai denis pour
ça on joue un peu pâle exactement se re
dans 15 ans on pensait donc c'est un bon
coup mort
[Musique]